pika shaidan wrong mean my name is wrong
min Hwan I'm 39 years old and I commute
between Thailand and Myanmar day we
dumped got can
been cool car and I'm a cook on a ship
i'm happy that i can live well for my
earnings each month hey yeah they're
beautiful cherry trees in japan well
that's why i'd like to go there or to
another country with beautiful cherry
blossoms choppy numpy gang song I like
Thai food especially meals with grilled
fish and roasted vegetables I like all
kinds of seafood top man
Troy time I to me globalization means i
can see the world joy to iowa i can
communicate with people from around the
world since i may I can you but I think
the number of people coming here is a
bit too much right now Korn Cowell you
hello my crotch shot LA and I caught ah
I don't need a lot for myself glad that
popcorn but i hope the situation in my
country stays good so that there will
always be enough for my family to live
on local you babe sabai sabai yeah you
come i shot my paw